five people have been arrested after a
border patrol agent was assaulted while
trying to stop migrants crossing our
southern border you can see some of the
agents injuries right here cbp says this
is the third attack against aegis in
this agents in the san ysidro sector in
the last month here to react retired
acting ice director and fox news
contributor
tom homan tom you see these images you
hear this story you obviously been
intimately involved in border patrol are
you surprised when you hear something
like this
no i'm not look the barbecue relations
job is inherently dangerous they've
already lost 142
deaths in the line of duty it's a
dangerous job and and i wore that
uniform i know it's like to be out there
so it's you know god bless him and thank
god she's recovering but what's really
shameful is the bite administration has
made their job who's already dangerous
much more dangerous because will when
you're in the middle of a crisis like
they are right now border patrol says 40
to 50
or their manpower is no longer online
because they're processing family units
taking care of them that means half the
board which relates you're on the line
which means your backup rather than
being 20 minutes away they're now
they're a half hour 45 minutes away and
the cartels know this so they know half
the board total agents are no longer
online that's when they move drugs and
and bad people across lines don't want
to be caught and a lot of ailing
smugglers carry weapons but almost all
narcotic smugglers carry weapons so so
the the incidents involving firearms and
fights are are skyrocketing because of
the nature of the crisis on the border
that's two fascinating stats you just
gave us so first of all half of border
patrol agents are called off the line to
be involved in essentially a
humanitarian effort in in providing care
to illegal immigrants but the other stat
you gave us 142 agents have lost their
life in the line of duty tom over what
kind of time period is that and by the
way while i'm asking you about that how
in what manner do border patrol agents
often lose their life
well look it's a lot of the shootings
out of this uh vehicle accidents they're
very rugged terrain some have fallen off
cliffs and let me mention one thing i
forgot to mention though there has been
10 covet deaths in the line of dewey
covert desk because they've been put in
the position
with covert crumbling across that border
thousands a day
and because the bite administration is
ignoring title 42 for families and
children and adults from other parts of
the country
these officers not only put harm through
every day because of the violence now
they got to deal with cope with coming
across the border because the bite
administration is letting a lot of
people in the country with coven
and so it's a dangerous job in in the
bite administration make it more
dangerous and these are men and women
that stand on that line every day while
you me are sleeping let me explain in
the middle of the night three o'clock in
the morning a sensor goes off on a
walking trail these men and women gonna
sit 20 minutes north of that center and
they're going to take on whatever comes
in the middle of the night is it someone
just coming for a better life or is it a
heavily armed drug smuggler we don't
know but these men and women don't stand
there and take it on while the rest is
country sleeping these are some of the
finest men and women this country has
and god bless them and and what happened
to this young lady is just an example
what these people deal with every day 24
7. let's take a quick look at this tom
there's this new video that shows the
arrest of illegal immigrants hiding in a
storm drainage system in texas i don't
know if we've got that video we can put
up on the screen yeah there we go
uh there's ten of them
down in this down in the storm drain
coming out what you know you look at
this tom what do you take away from that
again the criminal cartels are taking
advantage of the humanitarian crisis
they send large groups of families and
children through one part to tie all the
bourbon trough so they can sneak others
that don't want to get caught through
other parts of the border cartels make a
lot of money smuggling children and
families to the border to turn
themselves in but they really make the
money on narcotics and smuggling people
to their final destination like chicago
new york that that group was going to be
picked up by smugglers taken to a safe
house someplace where they're going to
wait for payoff relatives or somebody's
going to wire them money
to get them the rest of the way to
chicago that's where they make a lot of
their money so that we need to keep
focus on that this is just not a
humanitarian crisis that the smugglers
are still in a great business of
smuggling people into the interior of
the united states to their final
destination and many of them will be
carrying fentanyl over 90 000 fentanyl
deaths in this country because of this
crisis and because of the open border
yeah this one hasn't gone away
attention's been focused elsewhere but
this this crisis hasn't gone away tom
homan thank you so much